the murder trial stemming from a
controversial police shooting in Dallas
ended in a dramatic gesture of
forgiveness courtroom video captured
this emotional moment when the brother
of both Amjad the victim hugged former
police officer amber Geiger Geiger was
sentenced to 10 years in prison for
murdering Jean she could have received
up to 99 years outside protesters called
the sentence too lenient
Omar Villafranca was the first network
correspondent to sit down with both
Amazon's mother after the sentencing
Omar what did she have to say Alison
Jean told me she not only blames Amber
Geiger for the murder of her son but
she's also pointing her fingers at the
Dallas Police Department and the Texas
Rangers who led the investigation she's
also talking about that moment in court
when her youngest son hugged both his
killer but what he did today was
remarkable and he did it all on his own
the mother of both them John says she
was surprised by the moment her 18 year
old son Brandt offered forgiveness to
his brother's killer
amber Geiger I don't know if this is
possible but the young man just wanted
to say something after the sentencing
hearing
then Brandt and Geiger hug while Geiger
sobbed what branded was to cleanse his
hearts towards anger I do not want it to
be misconstrued as a complete Jean
family attorney Darrell Washington says
Brancheau Geiger the compassion both
them would have given if Amber Geiger
would have just spoken to both him when
she walked in the apartment
both them would have been the type of
guy that would say hey let me get you a
bowl Johnny have some ice cream
people angry over what they described as
a lenient sentence move their protests
from outside the courtroom to the street
overnight
Geiger will be eligible for parole after
five years we talked to you last year
what does justice look like is a murder
conviction and a 10-year prison sentence
justice to you a murder conviction for
sure
it's justice for me there is a lot that
has to be done by the Dallas Police
Department by the Texas Rangers by the
city of Dallas Dallas Police Chief Renee
Hall said she is launching an internal
affairs investigation into issues
revealed during the trial including
allegations of tampering with evidence
and protecting Giger I acknowledge that
there are things that we need to change
there are areas of concern that we need
to address we talked to you before the
trial and you said you were not quite
ready for forgiveness
where are you now I'm getting closer to
it the Jean family would also like to
see legislation passed in Bolton's name
that would require police to have more
training they say that if Tigard reacted
differently both them might still be
alive now we want to also show you
something else that happened in court
that was pretty unusual judge Tammy Kamp
hugged the John family then also walked
over and hugged Geiger and gave her a
Bible before she was led away meanwhile
this is not the end for Geiger her
attorneys are expected to file an appeal
Tony incredible scenes there in Dallas
Omar thank you very much really admire
the John family yes handling all of this
especially the brother and the mother
and the fact even the judge was crying
yesterday in court it's just a very
tragic tragic story everybody all the
way around case all the way around
indeed Omar thank you very much